I got a voicemail yesterday - at two one
nine to david p questioning my use of
the term abortion and i've heard this
from a few viewers and listeners so i
want to play the voicemail for you and
then respond to it take a listen hey
David it's listener Randle again I just
wanted to follow on there's a message I
just left you know with abortion and
choice being such a huge hot-button
topic in our society I just I just don't
get why you would use that word as an
adjective to describe something you
don't like it makes no sense to me I
just could you please please explain
yourself I'm here or please stop using
that term alright I'm no prude and I I
don't you know it's very hard to shock
me but I just don't I can't wrap my head
around why you're using that term yeah
so those of you here's the thing this
isn't about being prude or not and I've
heard this from people before they say
David if you're for a woman's right to
choose abortion if that's what's right
for her
why do you debt then use the term
abortion to refer to something negative
if you want women to have access to safe
and legal abortions if you look up the
word abortion in the dictionary you will
see two definitions one definition is
what is called a medical abortion the
second definition is the failure to do
something right if you attempt to pass
legislation to save people and actually
the legislation ends up leading to death
that would be an abortive thing that you
did the the legislation was a bun
abortion right and it has nothing to do
with medical abortion and I you know on
the one hand if it's so confusing to
people you could make the case that I
shouldn't use it but I actually think
that I don't want to be held hostage to
the fact that the word has become
incredibly politicized on one of the
definitions when it actually has this
other dictionary definition that has
nothing to do with medical abortion
another example of this would be the
word [ __ ] for someone with Down
syndrome
is not a word that's appropriate to use
period but the word to [ __ ] something
is a completely acceptable term that is
used whether you're talking about fire
retardants or to be a hard thrust on the
letter plan it's a delay or whatever and
it would be inappropriate to say that
the use of the word [ __ ] in that sense
is inappropriate or wrong because of the
stigma around Down syndrome right and
it's the same thing here my use of the
term abortion in that way has nothing to
do with the medical term abortion and I
don't think Pat that I should fall prey
to lack of linguistic awareness because
I think it is a very good word to
describe legislative failures in many
cases I wonder if the caller knows the
distinction between the two meanings or
if he when he hears the word abortion
his thoughts just go to the medical I
think so that's why it bothers them used
the word prude and he literally said why
do you say that about something bad when
you're in favor of abortion right and I
think that so I think that the column it
just simply may not know that let me
know if I if my analysis here is off and
I should just succumb to the demands and
no longer use the term in that way let
me know we've got a great bonus show
planned for you sign up get instant
access by becoming a member at WWE
pakman.com or by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show